خذوا الاقتصاديه يعصف بموظفي الشركات
الكبرى في الولايات المتحده كبرى شركه
الامريكيه والتكنولوجيه منها تحديدا اضطرت
الى التخلي عن الاف الموظفين والنزيف
لازال متوسط عنها وبشكل عام تقل صح حجم
الوظائف في الولايات المتحده بالنسبه 13%
في اكتوبر الماضي وهو الرقم الاعلى منذ
فبراير 2021 شركات عملاقها قامت بتسريح
موظفين كان اخرها اليوم شركه امازون التي
انهت خدمات 18 الف موظف في استكمالا
لسياسه بدات العمل منصرف نفس الشيء
بالنسبه لي تويتر التي قامت بتسريح ازيد
من 3500 موظف بعد استحواذ الا الله
قامت شركه مايكروسوفت لتسريح نحوي في موظف
في اكتوبر بدورها اعلنت شركه المختصه في
التواصل الاجتماعي طبعا في نوفمبر من
الالعاب الماضي انا هاستخفض ثلاثه عشر
بالمئه من قوتها العامله
يبدو ان الرئيس تنفيذ شركه امازون يسير
على خطى مالك شركه تويتر الى مصر الموظفين
امازون التي يعمل بها اكثر من مليون و500
الف شخص تستعد لتصريح اكثر من 18 الف موظف
الركود دفع شركات مثل النساء
على خفض الانسان
اركود الاقتصادي يؤثر على سوق العمل في
مختلف بوندان العالم غير ان قطع تكنولوجيا
كان مستهدفا بشكل كبير بحمله الاقالات
الاخيره التي تسببت فيها الازمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه العديد من العاملين
في هذا القطاع وجدوا انفسهم امام واقع
مختلف لا تتوفر فيه فرص عمل كافيه فضلا عن
تهديد مستمر بالاقاله سينما وان العديد من
الشركات بدات تجده بدائل الموظفين
المكلفين بالجانب التكنولوجي في ظل التطور
العلمي الحاصل في المجال فحسب استطلاع عن
اجرته مجله تكرانش المختصه في التكنولوجيا
فان حملات الاقالات الاخيره دفعت الكثير
من موظفي القطاع التكنولوجي الى التفكير
في المغادره هذا المجال الكليه
كورونا والحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تتسببان في ركود الاقتصادي
وحمالات الاقاله تتزايد في كل انحاء
العالم من اكثر الفئات المستهدفه موظفو
القطاع التكنولوجي في استطلاع لمجله
كشف العديد من موظفي القطاع عن غياب
الامان الوظيفي
واعلن اتجاه اكثر نحو المشاريع الخاصه
شركات التكنولوجيا بات تفضل عمل موظفيها
عن بعد كما تستخدم شركات التطور
التكنولوجي لحل محل الموظفين